[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans élémentaire
l'émission de Public Sénat qui cherche à
donner de la perspective ou de la
profondeur aux événements de l'actualité
en
1973 une organisation d'extrême droite
en France au RRE nouveau organiser un
meeting au Palais de la Mutualité à
Paris dont le thème était Hal à
l'immigration sauvage ça a d'ailleurs
tourné à l'émeut on peut à peu près
dater de cette époque l'irruption du
thème de l'immigration dans le débat
politique français il n'allait ensuite
cessé au cours des 50 années qui ont
suivi de s'amplifier et même de
s'exaspérer
50 années au cours de laquell nous avons
voté 30 lois sur l'immigration la 31e
est en cours d'examen aujourd'hui au
Parlement nous avons voulu essayer d'y
voir un peu clair dans ce
débat en de ça ou au-dà des fantases des
uns et des aveuglements des autres nous
avons intitulé cette émission
immigration vraie question et faux débat
et pour nous aider à ywir clair deux
experts l'une est démographe et l'autre
est économiste la démographe c'est
Michel tribala bonsoir bonsoir vous avez
fait toute votre carrière
professionnelle à Linet qui est
l'Institut de la démographie en France
vous êtes aujourd'hui retraité Vous avez
écrit de nombreux ouvrages dans le
dernier immigration idéologie et souci
de la vérité illustre votre propos
depuis que vous écrivez c'est-à-dire la
recherche qui vous a valu d'ailleurs des
ennuis et par moment avec l'extrême
gauche et par moment avec la
droite la recherche de des faits les
plus les plus proches possibles de la
vérité s'agissant d'une question
difficile sur le plan statistique on va
y revenir l'économiste c'est
Jean-Christophe Dumont bonsoir bonsoir
vous dirigez le département des
migration internationale à l'OCDE qui
est une référence en la matière et le
dernier rapport de l'OCDE sur
l'immigration date d'octobre dernier on
va essayer ensemble de de
de d'éclairer ce sujet autour de trois
thèmes d'abord les chiffres essayer de
voir avec vous de la manière la plus
simple possible qu quelle est la réalité
statistique de l'immigration en France
ensuite on va essayer de regarder les
questions la question de
l'intégration les ratés les réussites de
l'intégration et puis on on finira en en
essayant de voir des perspectives
quelles sont les politiques possibles
quelles sont celles qui marchent et qui
ne marchent pas mais commençons par les
chif
on va commencer avec vous Michel tribala
si vous le voulez bien première question
il y a combien d'immigrés en France
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on
sait pas mais en 2022 on sait donc en
2022 c'est 7 millions d'immigrés et
c'est à peu près 10,3 % de la population
d'accord en France
entière je dis je dis France entière
parce que de temps en temps c'est France
métro on a pas de séries qui sont bonord
7 million d'immigrés et combien ça ce
sont sont les immigrés légaux est-ce
qu'on a une idée de ce que sont du du
volume des immigrés illégaux ce ne sont
pas les immigrés légaux ce sont les
immigrés recensés dans les enquêtes
annuelles de recensement et qui
comprennent évidemment des immigrés qui
sont en situation illégale d'accord donc
moi je ne je n'ai pas d'estimation sur
le nombre d'illégaux en France il y a
des estimation qui don je sais que vous
n'aimez pas le doigt mouillé c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui ce qui vous rend
appréciable mais il y a des
estimations on dit même si elles sont
approximatives que on prend le nombre de
de de de gens qui bénéficie de l'aide
médicale laame c'est à peu près 300000
personnes moi j'aimerais savoir comment
c'est fait parce que vous pouvez avoir
des des gens qui sont inscrits et qui
qui sont comptés plusieurs fois je sais
pas je sais pas comment c'est fait donc
moi je me sers pas de ces chiffres là
Jean-Christophe vous avez des lumières
sur le nombre des illégaux alors
peut-être déjà pour pour rebondir sur
votre première question sur le nombre
d'immigrés en France madame tribala se
réfère à la définition de l'INC qui sont
des gens qui sont néstrangers à
l'étranger définition française
absolument oui euh mais effectivement en
comparaison internationale on peut pas
utiliser malheureusement cette
définition parce que les autres pays ne
comptabilisent pas les immigrés de la
même manière il compte l'ensemble des
personnes qui sont nées à l'étranger ce
qui dans le cas de la France nous
ramènerait à un chiffre plus proche de
13 % 12,8 en en 2022 et donc euh
peut-être que pour la comparaison en
tout cas avec les autres pays c'est ce
chiffre qu'il faut qu'il faut retenirir
euh mais cela dit sur votre question des
gens en situation irrégulière c'est
370000 bénéficiaires de l'aide médicale
d'État en en 2000 2020 euh même 2022 euh
en fait c'est très difficile de
d'extrapoler ce chiffre tout le monde ne
va pas effectivement bénéficier de cette
ame en dépit du fait fait d'être en
situation
irrégulière ce qui est sûr par contre
c'est que si on regarde l'évolution
entre 2004 et et donc les derniers
chiffres en 2004 on était environ à
150000 et maintenant on est à plus de
370000 donc il y a bien une augmentation
de l'immigration irrégulière donc donc
deux définitions du du des immigrés une
définition française une définition de
comparaison internationale et par
ailleurs une incertitude sur les sur les
îles égû oui je voudrais ajouter quelque
chose c'est-à-dire que euh la France
compte d'une certaine manière c'estàdire
les immigrés sont les personnes qui sont
venues en France en tant qu'étranger
et beaucoup de pays européens comptent
différemment il y en a pas enfin tout le
monde ne compte pas comme l'OCDE mais
les organismes internationaux Eurostat
l'OCDE les nations- Unies sont obligés
d'avoir une définition qui puisse
normaliser normaliser euh la chose et
qu'on puisse comparer donc c'est pour ça
que c'est pas la même combien y a-t-il
de descendant d'immigrés à la première
et enfin la 2è plutôt et la 3e
génération en France ce que vous appelez
les descendant de 2è génération je les
appelle de première génération si vous
voulez c'est les premières générations
né en France parce que si vous voulez
après on a on prend l'habitude d'appeler
tout le monde immigré et ces gens-là ne
sont pas immigrés puisquils sont nés en
France d'accord donc première génération
première génération on est en France on
a en 2022 7 mli3 d'accord donc à peu
près le même nom pardon 7 6 voyez j'ai
j'ai bien fait d'amener d'cord à peu
près le même nom la même proportion que
c'est un peu plus c'est un peu plus un
peu plus c'est un peu plus
donc génération moi j'ai fait une
estimation il y a longtemps aussi en
2011 sur les sur cette génération 2e
génération est en France pour les moins
de 60 ans et au total j'étais autour de
30 % en 2011 là on est je crois c'est 32
un truc comme ça 32 % 30 % ça intégrit
les immigrés la première génération et
et la deuxème génération ou seulement la
deè génération c'est seul non les
immigrés la génération première
génération en France les enfants les
petits- enfants mais pour les moins de
60 ans d'accord c'est ça ça ça recoupe
d'ailleurs je lisais les chiffres de
l'INC du dernier rapport de l'INC ça
recoupe à peu près ça dernière question
sur ce sur ces chiffres et puis après on
va regarder les comparaisons
internationales avec les réserves que
vous avez évoqué la la la dynamique si
on prend disons depuis les années 70
alors moi je vous m'avez parlé d'une
quarantaine d'années donc je vous ai
pris 82 voyez 82 2022 très bien donc
mais alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est 82
c'est France métropolitaine et 2022
c'est France entière donc il y a un tout
petit décalage en tout cas quand vous
regardez donc en en 1982 on avait 4
millions d'immigrés et c'était 7,4 % de
la population juste une question
là-dessus parce que c'est un thème qui
qui intervient dans le débat et puis on
va passer au comparaisons internationale
c'est un thème qui intervient souvent
dans le débat le grand remplacement dont
vous avez contesté même l'idée la
submersion est-ce que c'est est-ce que c
ces expressions vous paraisse convenir à
la situ à la dynamique d'évolution de
l'immigration en France non j'ai j'ai
j'ai pas tant condamné l'expression
parce que l'expression elle est en fait
mal
interprétée l'idée de grand remplacement
c'est c'est c'est exprime la crainte en
fait de de de de de perdre la majorité
dans ce pays mais c'est une crainte qui
est qui est pas forcément immédiate donc
t t tous les éléments factuels que vous
pouvez apporter là si je dis si je si je
dis à des gens qui craignent d'être que
que c'est 10 % je veux dire bon ça n'a
aucun effet si vous voulez c'est une
crainte qui est liée à ce qui vivent
localement oui j'entend bien observent
donc j'entends bien mais mais mais quand
on regarde d'ailleurs ça me permet de de
d'interroger Jean-Christophe Dumont mais
quand si on regarde la dynamique la
situation de l'immigration par exemple
en France si je la compare à d'autres
pays voisins et notamment à celui qui
est le plus proche de nous l'Allemagne
quels sont les comment vous comment vous
compareriez ces deux situations à la
fois statiquement aujourd'hui la
photographie de l'immigration et et de
manière dynamique les faits
euh tendent à montrer que si la France a
été un un grand pays d'imigration
effectivement ça environ un/art de la
population qui a au moins un de ces deux
parents qui est qui est immigré
effectivement quand on vient en
grands-parents un de ces quatre
grands-parents immigrés je sais pas où
est-ce qu'il faut où est-ce qu'il faut
arrêter tirer le trait euh c'est plutôt
beaucoup en comparaison européenne en
tout cas c'est plutôt dans la dans le
haut de la distribution quand on regarde
en revanche le nombre de personnes qui
sont nées à
l'étranger donc on l'a dit c'est un peu
plus de 10 % pour les immigrés au sens
de l'INC c'est près de 30 13 % pour les
gens qui sont nés à l'étranger en France
c'est largement moins que dans
l'ensemble des autres pays européens
auquels on aime bien se comparer euh
c'est 16,8 % en Allemagne c'est plus de
18 % en Belgique c'est 20 % en Irlande
c'est 20 % en Suède donc si on regarde
euh cette population née à l'étranger en
France en réalité on a une proportion
qui est moindre que dans les autres pays
donc c'est vrai en effectif global c'est
aussi vrai en flux euh quand on regarde
le nombre de personnes qui chaque année
viennent s'installé en France on est
entre pour les derniers chiffres entre
0,4 et 0,5 % de la population c'est
environ la moitié de la moyenne des pays
de l'OCDE on a des pays qui sont à plus
de 1 % de leur
population abondé par l'immigration
chaque année donc la France a été un
grand pays d'immigration c'est un grand
pays mais en comparaison internationale
l'immigration pèse moins que chez ses
voisins ouis moi je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord la France est encore si on on
compare à l'histoire c'est encore un
grand pays d'immigration par rapport à
ce qu'elle a connu quand quand on
regarde l'évolution sur sur des périodes
comme 54 75 et 1999 2022 c'est des
périodes à peu près équivalentes la
proportion d'immigrés accru en moyenne
annuelle de la même façon au même taux
c'estàd si on a trouvé qu'il y avait une
forte immigration à la sortie de la
guerre dans ces années-là il y a une
forte immigration elle est moins forte
que dans certains pays mais pour
l'Allemagne la comparaison intéressante
c'est c'est surtout d'où ils viennent
alors j'allais venir à ça ça quand on
regarde la composition de l'immigration
si on fait une comparaison entre la
France et
l'Allemagne ce qu'on lit est-ce que
c'est vrai est-ce que c'est faux
monsieur Dumont
c'est on a une double caractéristique
par rapport à l'Allemagne la première
c'est que la part des
immigrés il y a une forte concentration
géographique des origines géographiques
sur l'Afrique en tout cas dans les dans
la périodes récentes de de l'immigration
vers la France et deuxièmement il y a un
niveau de qualification inférieur est-ce
que c'est vrai ou est-ce que c'est faux
alors c'est faux euh notamment sur le
deuxème point et sur le premier c'est
c'est en partie vraie ce qui est vrai
c'est que l'immigration en France elle
reste dominée dans les flux et dans les
effectifs par les pays du Maghreb c'est
incontestable il y a sur la période
récente et ça correspond en fait à des
petits effectifs une augmentation de
l'immigration en provenance d'Afrique
subsaharienne notamment des pays
francophones d'Afrique subsaharienne
mais il y a aussi une diversification
avec une immigration européenne qui pour
le coup est beaucoup plus faible qu'en
Allemagne l'Allemagne a reçu beaucoup
d'immigrés d'immigrés européens ces
enfin ces dernières décennies mais elle
elle reçoit aussi beaucoup plus de
Syriens par exemple suite évidemment à
la crise de 2015-216 elle reçoit
beaucoup plus d'Ukrainiens c'est environ
70000 Ukrainiens qui sont en France
c'est 100002 en Allemagne elle reçoit
aussi beaucoup plus de de ressortissants
des anciens ens pays de l'Union
soviétique notamment des aosidler
pasosedler c'est des gens d'origine
allemande c'est plus de de de de 2
millions de personnes qui sont venu à ce
moment-là et puis évidemment il y a la
grande migration turque et yougoslave
vers l'Allemagne qui qui qui pèse
beaucoup donc elle a aussi une forte
concentration vers certains pays
d'origine qui sont pas les mêmes que
ceux de la France mais cette
concentration est un phénomène qu'on
retrouve dans beaucoup de pays avec
cette petite nuance je voudrais préciser
quelque chose je dire quand on compare
la population d'origine étrangère en
Allemagne et en France donc les les
immigrés et les descendants il y en a
beaucoup plus en Allemagne qu'en France
mais je vaux dire il y a plus d'extra
européens en France qu'en Allemagne en
nombre absolu et en proportion c'est ce
que c'est ce que vous disiezou c'est
absolument ou ça me permet de de pardon
on est obligé d'aller vite mais ça
permet de situer le débat ça me permet
de vous aviez posé excusez-moi une
question aussi sur le niveau des
d'instruction des immigrés en France en
comparaison avec l'Allemagne c'est c'est
à ça que que que je résistais un petit
peu par rapport à votre question et donc
en France il y a cette idée que
l'immigration est principalement peu
qualifié c'est c'est c'est une vision un
petit peu déformée du phénomène
migratoire en réalité c'est 35 % des
immigrés qui sont diplômés du supérieur
en France et si on regarde ceux qui sont
arrivés depuis moins de 5 ans on est à
41 % de diplômés du supérieur ce qui se
compare exactement à la proportion de
diplômés du supérieur dans la population
française on est à 40 % donc à peu près
au même niveau en revanche ce qui
caractérise la France c'est une forte
proportion de gens qui ont un très
faible niveau d'éducation à côté de ces
gens qui sont diplômés du supérieur il y
a environ quatre fois plus que dans la
population française de gens qui ont
plus un niveau d'éducation primaire en
Allemagne il y a beaucoup moins
d'immigrés qui sont diplômé du supérieur
on est autour de 29 % donc la France de
ce point de vue-là se compare
favorablement à l'Allemagne mais moins
qui mais moins en Allemagne qui sont
très faiblement diplômés également une
proportion importante que je peux qui
est autour de 16 %
1%% une précision pour la pour la
comparaison France- Allemagne si vous
voulez nous on a une très très forte
participation africaine dans les dans
les chez les personnes d'origine extra
eururopéenne et eux c'est l'Asie en fait
voilà on est dans des proportions
voisines mais nous c'est l'Afrique et
eux c'est l'Asie bon j'aurais bien aimé
qu'on dise un mot de l'intégration des
profils deintégration mais on va pas
avoir le temps parce que parce que de de
regarder mais peut-être juste un mot
là-dessus avant qu'on parle des
politiques euh quand on regarde les les
évolutions à une ou deux générations
quand on prend des des critères
socioculturels le taux de chômage le
taux de diplôme la le taux de fécondité
le taux de nuptialité les Mar non pas
taux de fécondité s'il vous plaît
d'accord ok l'indice de fécondité ou
absolument d'accord bon alors oublion la
fécondité est-ce que est-ce que les
est-ce que les critères la batterie de
critères de de de socioculturel montre
un processus d'intégration efficace si
on compare nos voisins moins efficace
que par le passé plus efficace qu'est-ce
qu'on peut dire de de ça de manière un
peu statistique alors les comparaisons
en terme d'intégration sont sont
toujours un petit peu difficiles parce
que si vous comparez la Suède qui a
principalement qui accueille
principalement des réfugiés avec le
Canada qui a une immigration très
sélective évidemment vous allez obtenir
des résultats qui sont plus favorables
au au Canada qu'en qu'en Suède donc la
composition de l'immigration elle
explique une partie de ces résultats
mais si on s'en tient évidemment au taux
d'emploi ou au taux de chômage comme
vous le disiez en France c'est environ
62 % des immigrés qui sont qui sont en
emploi c'est environ 8 points de
pourcentage de moins que pour les natifs
c'est un écart qui a euh qui est
relativement stable euh et qui euh qui
est en réalité en niveau donc on a un
taux d'emploi plus faible qu'en
Allemagne on est presque à 70 % de de de
taux d'emploi mais où l'écart avec les
natifs est aussi plus important parce
qu'il est à 9 points en France euh il y
a pendant longtemps et je pense que
là-dessus avec madame tribala je pense
qu'on pourrait se rejoindre euh il y a
eu un déficit en terme de politique
d'intégration euh aujourd'hui il y a des
efforts qui sont euh qui sont soutenus
notamment en terme d'apprentissage de la
langue et en terme d'accueil au travers
du contrat d'insertion républicaine euh
mais pendant des décennies ce cet effort
a été tout à fait dilué dans la
politique de de la ville et en partie
des des des des difficultés qu'on
observe aujourd'hui elle ell elles ont
trait à ce manque d'investissement sur
le long terme à des effets de
concentration géographique dans des
quartiers défavorisés et sans doute à un
effet trop faible de l'école comme
ascenseur social dans la société
française ou pour ce qui est des
concentrations on en trouve partout hein
je veux dire l'Allemagne aléienne la
Suède aléienne nous avons les nôtres et
je pense pas que enfin sur
l'apprentissage de la langue il faut
savoir que on a été absolument très
négligeent puisque on a essayé de copier
les Pays-Bas qui
qui insistait pour
avoir des cours et un résultat et nous
on a forcé à assister à des cours de
français mais ce qui comptait c'était
d'y être et pas les résultats donc bon
je sais pas si on a fait une
photographie de la situation mais en en
tout cas on des éléments mais quand on
se projette dans l'avenir euh j'ai j'ai
vous m'avez très justement signalé les
les déclaration de la Commission
européenne récemment et le le le
l'analyse qui est faite par beaucoup du
fait que d'un côté le vieillissement de
la population du vieux continent mais de
la France en particulier moi pas
seulement de la France hein je dire
l'autre le les les besoins de main
d'œuvre du marché du travail
d'équilibrage des comptes sociaux porte
plutôt à penser que ces phénomène
migratoire non seulement ne vont pas se
réduire mais vont plutôt s'amplifier
c'est dire c'est très clair la
Commission européenne ne compte que sur
l'immigration pour éviter je vais dire
un déclin accéléré de la population
européenne puisqu'elle reçoit les les
projections d'Eurostat les dernières
2023 qui sont absolument catastrophiques
en en terme de
d'anticipation de toute façon déjà déjà
le solde naturel de l'Union européenne
est
négatif on a 1,25 million de décès en
plus que de naissance dans l'année de
départ de la projection qui est 2022
donc et ça s'arrange pas après donc si
vous voulez sur un
long temps une longue
durée l'Union européenne reçoit des
projections dans lesquelles je veux dire
la la tion native décroit à grande
vitesse et donc dans ce dans ce cadre
qui qui a l'air assez
consensuel est-ce que est-ce que enfin
peut-être pas d'ailleurs mais est-ce que
est-ce qu'une politique de contrôle de
l'immigration a un sens quelconque ou
bien est-ce que ou est-ce que l'idée que
qu'agit certains d'une politique
d'immigration
sélective diversifiant les origines
culturelles augmentant le niveau de
qualification est un un vux pieux ou ou
est jouable là j'essaie de de projeter
un peu de manière un peu globale sur les
politiques les cadres théoriques des
politiques possibles il y a il y a
beaucoup de questions dans votre
question donc on va essayer de
unu absolument la question démographique
il y a un fait que la natalité est en
baisse et notamment dans les pays
d'Europe du Sud dans les pays d'Europe
de l'Est le le le phénomène est très
accentué et donc mécanique partout en
Europe de l'Est hein Roumanie et tie il
sont ils sont au niveau de la
franceécaniquement mécaniquement le la
l'immigration en en proportion joue un
rôle de plus en plus important parce que
effectivement elle s'accroit dans un
contexte de baisse de de la natalité de
sorte que effffectivement aujourd'hui la
croissance de la population européenne
est entièrement enfin en tout cas de la
population active européenne est
entièrement du euh à l'immigration mais
c'est pas le résultat d'une politique
migratoire c'est le résultat plutôt de
pas seulement des flux d'une baisse de
la natalité en réalité c'est plutôt dans
l'autre sens de de l'autre côté de
l'équation qu'il faut qu'il faut
regarder alors je je suis je me porte un
peu en en en en en en faux concernant
cette cette idée que l'Union européenne
ne verrait euh disons euh que euh grâce
à à l'immigration pour résoudre tous les
défis qui qui sont portés à l'Union
européenne que ce soit en terme de
transition verte que ce soit en terme de
digitalisation de l'économie ou
simplement de de compétitivité de
l'économie européenne la migration fait
partie des instruments qui sont qui sont
disponibles mais c'est c'est ni ni le
principal euh ni ni le seul et donc par
rapport au au aux politiques
d'immigration je pense qu'il faut il
faut éviter de de de généraliser et de
présenter la migration d'abord comme un
comme un tout elle se compose de
différentes catégories à commencé par la
migration intraeuropéenne qui fait
partie simplement et en France c'est
près de 90000 personnes qui chaque année
viennent s'installer d'autres pays
européens ça ça compte pour environ un/
ce de l'immigration en France mais c'est
pas celle-là qui crée du débat politique
alors néanmoins c'est celle qui vient
abonder le marché du travail et et
contribuer à la part de l'immigration
dans l'augmentation de la force de de de
la population active deuxièmement il y a
évidemment l' l'immigration familiale
l'immigration familiale qui pèse à peu
près autant que l'immigration
intra-européenne en France mais qui est
principalement composé maintenant euh de
du rapprochement de de conjoints de
Français ou d'Européens euh et donc
c'est pas forcément des étrangers qui
font venir leur famille et donc cette
immigration de droit n'est évidemment
pas sujette à à cotas ou à disons
sélection ou ou critèrees d'éducation
donc en fait la part de l'immigration
qu'on va qualifier de discrétionnaire
sur laquelle on peut vraiment agir c'est
l'immigration de travail cette
immigration de travail elle a été c'est
vrai en très forte augmentation ces
dernières années en France elle a triplé
en 10 ans donc elle est passée de 16000
à 52000 en 2020 enfin en 2012 à à à
52000 en 2022 elle est principalement
qualifiée et pour la moitié en fait elle
est le fait d'étudiants qui ont fait
leurs études en France et qui changent
de statut à l'issue de de leurs études
elle est très qualifiée et elle explique
donc ces 41 % d'immigrés diplômé du
supérieur dans les moins de 5 ans que je
mentionnais précédemment vous partagez
ce point de vue euh non pas vraiment non
pas vraiment je veux dire euh c'est une
c'est un point de vue qui repose sur les
besoins
c'està-dire une élite décide qu'il a
qu'on a besoin d'immigration pour les
pour combler les les pénuries de main
d'œuvre et donc c'est c'est c'est c'est
une espèce de dictate qui doit
s'appliquer d'ailleurs c'est c'est c'est
la
Commission en la matière pour que pour
récupérer la la partie économique de la
migration mais moi la question que je me
pose c'est est-ce que est-ce que la
politique migratoire est un objet
politique encore vous voulez dire quoi
est-ce que est-ce que ça peut faire
l'objet d'une décision souveraine du du
peuple d'accord démocratique donc alors
je constate que ça ça ça ça n'est pas le
cas en tout cas dans dans les élites je
dirais
journalistique chercheur et politique et
notamment puisque on a on a en fait
naturaliser l'immigration c'estàd on
nous dit François Iran par exemple le
professeur au Collège de France nous dit
que c'est comme les naissance c'est
comme la c'est comme le vieillissement
et donc on dit peut rien quoi c'est
c'est comme ça et Monsieur Darmanin dans
dans une conférence au centre de
réflexion la sécurité intérieure 19
septembre nous disait exactement je le
cite l'immigration n'est pas une
question d'opinion publique être contre
c'est être c'est être c'est commeêtre
contre le soleil voyez donc si on peut
pas naturaliser plus la chose donc voilà
un ministre qui nous prépare une loi sur
l'immigration en disant qu' tout changer
et qui par ailleurs dit on n'y peut rien
les gars c'est comme le soleil B voilà
c'est c'est quand même problématique
merci donc on a bien vu à la fin de
notre discussion qu'il y a deux deux
façons d'aborder la chose l'une qui
consiste à dire bon ben il y a des des
contraintes démographiques ouou
économiques et c'est ça qu'on est en
train de gérer de droit et et vous qui
dites mais c'est après tout une question
souveraine et on pourrait aller
contre c ces choses qu'on nous présente
comme naturell ou ou un cont aller
contre moi je dis pas qu'il faut aller
contre je dis je dis une politique
migratoire qui ne peut jamais euh
freiner l'immigration n'en est pas une
c'est tout je vous remercie tous les
deux de vos lumières je sais bien que
les faits n'entrent pas dans le monde
des croyances comme disait Marcel Prous
mais j'espère que ce soir nous sommes
parvenir à établir quelques uns des
faits qui permettront et de et que nous
n'aurons pas fait perdre notre temps à à
ceux qui nous ont qui eu la gentillesse
de nous écouter que nous les aurons
enrichis et
nourr en tout cas merci à eux de nous
avoir suivi merci à vous deux de nous
avoir éclairé ou d'avoir posé les termes
du débat cette émission peut-être revue
sur le site
publicsenat.fr pour ceux qui ne
l'auraient pas vu ce soir ou ceux qui
ont envie de l' revir merci à vous deux
et bonsoir merci à vous
merci